bienvenidos france24 en principio le
pregunto que representa el mes sagrado
del ramadán
se llama le di con moras contrajo para
que hacer que la paz esté contigo
pues qué significa es el mes exactamente
donde el corán fue revelado y es un mes
donde te enfocas en
espiritualmente
pues no solamente te vienes o te reta
acá de
recatadas de comer y beber sino es un
tiempo de reflexión es un tiempo donde
pones
pones la vida mundial a un lado y te
pocas más en lo que es la vida
espiritual
es el mes donde más se da al pobre es el
tercer pilar de los cinco pilares del
islam y pues somos 1.8 millones de
musulmanes que empezaremos a ayunar el
día de mañana ya se vio la luna nsai
arabia entonces el ramadán empieza
oficialmente y empezó en algunos países
para nosotros aquí en texas empieza a la
caída del sol esta tarde y pues es un
mes realmente
reflexión y de compasión y de recordar a
los pobres a los que tienen menos pues
es un mes donde realmente te enfocas en
ti en ti mismo y pues la verdad todo
musulmán lo espera con ansias muchas
veces piensan que el no comer el no
beber es algo muy frustrante o algo muy
difícil pero todo lo contrario es algo
que estamos esperando todo el año y le
pedimos siempre hablar que nos que nos
bendiga a poder llegar a este mes y cuál
es el significado por ejemplo de ese
ayuno y del cambio de hábitos durante el
ramadán
pues nuevamente es una reflexión
personal es un tiempo donde pues te das
cuenta lo que siente alguien que no
tiene comida que no tiene provisión o
que vive en zonas donde es difícil como
acabas de mencionar muchos lugares están
han elevado sus precios entonces pues
uno como que vivimos aquí en los estados
unidos y somos muy bendecidos pues se
toma esto más ese tiempo para realmente
reflexionar todas tus bendiciones
entonces cuentas tus bendiciones y no
tengo no no te enfocas en lo que no
tienes sino en lo que tienes y no
solamente monetario pero la salud es
algo que acabamos estamos saliendo de
una pandemia entonces es algo muy
importante que a veces no contamos todas
las bendiciones la bendición de poder
ver de poder escuchar de poder caminar
entonces en este mes
realmente te sientas y pues a través de
leer el corán también reflexionas lo que
habla nos está diciendo en esta guía que
nos
a través del profeta mohamed que la paz
esté con él y pues si son 30 días donde
la verdad que cuando ya está terminando
el ramadán lo sentimos no queremos que
termine el ramadán bueno y brevemente le
pregunto este año está marcado por las
complicaciones generadas por los precios
por el aumento de los precios de los
alimentos
principalmente en medio oriente y en el
norte de áfrica pero de alguna manera
usted se está viendo afectada por esta
situación
la verdad no pero durante este mes
nosotros también practicamos practicamos
en sí los cuatro pilares de los cinco
pilares y otro pilar que se practica en
este mes del ramadán es el shaka que
básicamente tú das
2.5 de tus bienes que has ahorrado en un
año
y se lo dejas a los pobres a los
necesitados a fundaciones que tienen
escuelas hay diferentes lugares donde tú
puedes dar